ah
[Music]
pitiful
oh what
who are you
where
are my manners
sonic
meat knuckles
my new bffae
bestest friend forever and ever
look robotnik i don't care who you
brought to help you you're never going
to get my power do i look like i need
your power
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the hype
where is it oh you want it
here it comes i was expecting more of
you
though i'm
skilled
untrained
and
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
ah
[Music]
it is my destiny to do what my ancestors
could not to restore the ultimate power
to the home of my people
uh ultimate power i don't know what
you're talking about
you've got the wrong guy
ultimate power
now you speaking my language don't play
dumb with me apprentice of long floor
you knew long claw look lord her people
were the sworn enemy of my tribe the
echidna we fought and died at their
hands and now you will die
come on get in i'm on your side i'm
sorry who are you
you know what it doesn't matter
get us out of here
he's got rabbit
gross
[Music]
make sure to get your shot egg man